the avengers has all of the peop all of
the superheroes there but we're not
following each of them separately in all
the things that they're doing right we
may be following them as a group and
then following one or two of them who
may be doing something separately and
the others are just there for support in
this particular movie
do writers get confused with subplot
versus plot how do we know the
difference yeah i'm going to assume that
if you're saying subplot that you mean
different storylines and that's the way
that i kind of like to talk about it and
i don't think i've seen too many people
get confused with it but
not really knowing how to use them and
make them impactful for each other so
when i describe sub characters i
describe them as characters who are
helping or hindering the protagonist's
goal
we only care about these sub characters
because they are pushing the a story
forward
that doesn't mean that those characters
don't also have their own story lines
because they're people and they should
be doing things other than walking
around behind your protagonist all day
right however
the point of their stories is to
eventually crash
into the a story eventually complicate
the a story eventually help the a story
even if they look like they're going
this for this way at some point
they're gonna you know connect and so i
think some people miss that and they
will then start to write an entirely
different story
for the b story that has absolutely
nothing to do with the a story
and now we're watching these two stories
go but they're not connected right so
going back to our family reunion if i
were to come to your family reunion i
expect to meet your cousins
not your neighbor's cousins
so those subcharacters are here because
they're important to this protagonist
they're not other random people in the
world
those random people weren't invited to
the barbecue right the people who are
here the people who are um helping or
hurting
informing helping complicating what's
going on with the protagonists so we
only care about them because of their
proxy you know their proximity to the
protagonist so i think people don't
understand that and they just say oh
my subplot or my b story is just another
story
it's like no thematically they tie plot
wise they tie
something about them connects them all
and uh a great example of that is crash
the music crash right because there are
50 million main characters but they're
all dealing with the same kind of things
and they all eventually
connect
right so spoiler alert they all
eventually get you to this dead kid who
is the brother of one of those people
who was killed by one of the other
people right so it all starts to connect
when we first start to watch it we're
like why do we need to be following all
these people what is what is going on
but it's because
their world is smaller than we think it
is they are all in the same world and
they will all
affect that a story so in that
particular film i haven't seen it in a
little while but i wouldn't say there's
a standout protagonist unless we'll say
it's don cheadle's character who is the
detective maybe but instead it seems
like we just have a lot of main
characters and they each have their own
storylines right but the a plot is what
happened to this
this boy because we open up with
learning that someone died
um so the main plot is what happened to
this boy and then we go into all of
these other stories to eventually come
back to oh that's what happened but then
beyond that um
the themes are about how we're all just
people regardless of our differences so
it talks a lot about race and religion
and all these other things so each of
those groups of people is dealing with
that theme on their own level so that
still connects them they're they're not
random stories that are being told
they're all connected so if people can
understand that about subplot or like i
like to call them story lines or a story
b story c story east d story however
many story lines you're going to have
they all have to connect and they all
have to push your a story forward even
if when they first start it seems like
it has nothing to do with that
eventually it all has to come back to
this one thing or at least thematically
tie and the theme is usually again going
to be shown in your a story so that
means all of the other storylines are
still going to thematically tie into
them
let's take this family barbecue
so let's say everybody's happy
everything's wonderful
and then there's another scene where
there's a man and maybe a beat up
vehicle who's delivering something and
it's his personal vehicle and he's
stressing out he's in traffic and you
know people are cutting him off whatever
and he's trying to be a decent driver
but he finally gets there and he's
sweating and he unloads this cake for
this barbecue and
when he delivers it
he finds out
that one of the children there that's
actually his kid
and the wife and he had been estranged
for years
and now
this happy moment
is awful because all the memories have
come back and he hasn't seen the sun in
years because it was too it was too
difficult yeah and so now
he's this subplot has now come into the
main plot exactly okay
okay
and so then
how so then how long does this sub
character stay
at that barbecue yeah it depends on your
story going back to
what's the goal
is the goal for
him to
[Music]
have the realization of this was my
family because if so then that's the end
of the movie
everything got us to the moment that he
arrived right
if the story is about
working on getting my family back or
working on rekindling with my son or you
know whatever that was then it could be
the inciting incident that he shows up
with the cake it could be the midpoint
that he shows up with the cake right so
we've been seeing him he had his goal i
need to deliver this cake
we're watching up until the midpoint
everything that he's trying to do to
deliver the cake i don't know what's
happening with the other family but they
have their own goals and whatever
they're doing preparing for the barbecue
whatever they're doing right or
attending the barbecue and dealing with
family drama because they're already
talking about
her ex-husband and blah blah you know
that kind of thing um
so when he shows up at the midpoint
now things are redirected right so
what's happening for the rest of the
time is it stay here and work it out
because this is the scene right it's
it's pandemic so people aren't doing a
lot of different locations and blah blah
blah so do we stay here and work out the
whole thing or
does that end the barbecue scene and now
we go into the rest of life
as he's trying to rekindle the
relationship so depending upon what that
goal is then you know how long this
barbecue thing needs to happen or this
journey to the barbecue in the first
place and then what scenes we need after
that for him to actually reach his goal
and if you've done your work of making
the goal relevant
while he's preparing this cake while
he's driving through traffic while he's
doing blah blah blah we will learn that
there is a loneliness there we will
learn that there is a
like maybe we don't want to give it away
that he lost his child you know whatever
that stuff is but we're getting some
information to know
that there's something he's missing
something that he's needing something
he's given up on maybe it's because
people are calling as he's driving and
he's i don't want to talk about it man
you know blah blah whatever that is
we'll start to know something else is
going on here so that when he arrives
with that cake and he gets out of the
car and stops short yeah
no one has to say anything right we know
because we've been given the evidence
that something's going on with him and
we've been given the evidence at the
barbecue as she's been setting up and oh
he's of this and he's that and we've
been hearing
the stuff it hasn't been like you know
the a story because it wasn't yet but
now that these two things have collided
they'll make one storyline and we'll go
on from there
how many subplots should a movie have or
a tv show have yeah so there isn't
necessarily a set amount but what i will
say is
your a story is going to be in every
single one of your acts
fully out
some
movies will only have an a story
um
if you have a b story it's now still all
of the same amount of beats
but shorter
right so if your a story is this long
your b story might be that long
your c story and d story and e story all
get shorter but they're still full story
lines which means they have their own
goals their own complications climaxes
etc
in a television show you're usually only
gonna have maybe about three
per episode even if you have
six or seven characters like if you
watch this is us
something's gonna be going on with one
of the big three something's going to be
going on with mom and dad in the past
and then we may also be watching
something else maybe
um in a show like brothers and sisters
there were five kids and a mom so maybe
we're definitely gonna have at least
three story lines but there might be a
fourth small nugget of something that's
giving us bread crumbs from something
bigger that's gonna happen you know down
the road um
what i will say is
in features it's good to have at least
more than one storyline depending on the
genre most horror movies have one
storyline stay alive protagonist
that's it they're also usually only 75
minutes long so we don't really have
time to be following up and other people
and whatever else is going on we're just
trying to stay in this one little thing
but other than that um it's good to have
a b story because you want to break up
the monotony of the a story because
again once we get into the second act
it's about reaching that goal and if i'm
just if every single page is about what
this one person is doing that can become
monotonous right it becomes like get
there or don't get there you know we
start to get a little impatient so if
you have something to break it up with
another storyline another full story
line then that can kind of help keep the
uh pacing up
you know i've seen it a lot in love
stories a lot of love stories will just
have the love
but how much can we take uh together not
together together not together together
not together it's like do they have
anything else that they can be doing you
know like what's going on in their
personal lives that can be a b and a c
story you know what i mean what's going
on with mom that that can thematically
tie to what's happening with them that
we can be watching because if not then
we can start to get disinterested by the
redundancy because it's a relationship
how much can they really go through even
if it's a new piece of conflict it still
ends in the same thing be together or
don't right so if we keep watching them
do this
for 40 minutes i mean that we need to
break that up a little bit so it's
always good to have another but in
general there isn't a standard i think
that
you can figure out if you've if you've
um
gotten too many of them if things start
to get a little messy and you can't
really follow
the storylines um
like even if you look at a marvel film
uh at the avengers right the avengers
has all of the peop all of the
superheroes there but we're not
following each of them separately in all
the things that they're doing right we
may be following them as a group and
then following one or two of them who
may be doing something separately and
the others are just there for support in
this particular movie and that's okay so
you want to definitely make sure that it
doesn't become too much like if you look
at um at crash that was i don't know how
many people that was but there was a lot
of story lines but they were simple
enough
right simple
and thematic so each time we came to
them we were kind of mirroring whatever
just happened with the other group of
people on their side of town or getting
them closer to meeting one of the other
group of people so it worked for them so
that's why again it's everything is
going to come down to what's best for
your story so you have to be paying
attention to that pacing and am i
spending enough time to understand what
this storyline is or am i just dropping
a couple of people every now and again
which now confuses us so instead of it
breaking up the monotony it's confusing
us and we have more questions so you
just have to again find another pair of
eyes if you can't figure it out right
hire a script consultant like myself
there are plenty of us out there or have
someone who understands story at least
to read it to see how it's making them
feel and what information they're
missing
so with this family barbecue story if we
have this dad that's now bringing this
cake and now the rest of the family's
just stunned
that he's doing this job and that he's
there and that he's actually shown
himself
you know maybe there were calls that say
don't come by anymore who knows what
happened
um if we were to add another character
it would somehow have to make it in it
can't just be the random guy at the bar
that he goes
pounds a drink and he goes hey man slow
down what's wrong and oh you know i
can't talk about it somehow that guy at
the bar has to be part of the story
i mean again
every sub character has
their own role to play
meeting a guy in a bar doesn't have to
become a story line okay that sub
character could just be the person in
the bar that had some kind of
conversation with our actual character
that motivated or changed them to go do
something
right okay so that person doesn't have
to become a storyline that person can
just be a guy in the bar who said
whatever but whatever it is he said had
to have changed our character because if
not then we don't need this conversation
we don't need this bar we don't need
this location we need to pay for these
people
or any of that right right okay so that
so that's going to be the difference but
if i watched guy at bar at home and then
watched guy at bar get to the bar then i
watched guy at bar drive away from the
bar then now i'm asking myself okay what
does this guy bar have to do with any of
this right because now i'm watching
their life from their point of view
so
does guy from barr end up being her new
boyfriend
right
so he didn't know that when they were
sitting next to each other these two men
when they're talking about the situation
and gaiabar is like you should go get
your family back
right and now guy with cake shows up at
the barbecue and then guy with bar a guy
from the bar drives up what are you
doing here getting my family back
oh that's my girl
we've got something going on now these
story lines are connecting
i was actually thinking
that the guy at the bar would be a
negative
reflection of the of the protagonist
that he didn't want to ever become and
so he sees himself in that guy at the
bar and he go and the guy at the bar is
drunk and he's like yeah my ex-wife
she's a you-know-what and you know i
just you know whatever i i i walked out
a long time ago and and hey johnny get
me another bourbon or whatever and then
he sees like i could become that man
right and i don't want to be that and
that straightens him out yep and that so
in that case then he's just a sub
character
okay he doesn't have his own storyline
okay so he's not a subplot yeah he's not
a subplot he's just a sub character he's
just a character who's helping to push
the story forward by his interaction
with this guy but a storyline would mean
that the guy at the bar has his own
goals and we're following him trying to
achieve those goals too
and then eventually they align with what
everybody else has going on i see okay
so he's a catalyst
okay yeah interesting just coming in to
push you in one direction or the other
because again if not then we don't need
him
right we don't need a guy who's just at
the bar being belligerent
that that belligerence should
affect our guy in some kind of way
because if not then we don't need that